by far the biggest show on Broadway
right now is a molten yeah that's guess
what guess what since we're here in New
York I think it's time a comedy show
finally had the courage to do a Hamilton
parody finally yes you guys want to see
[Applause]
6:7
[Applause]
thanks everybody matthew matthew
broderick what are you doing here
well Conan kaan I'm sorry you just you
can't do it you cannot do this why not
why can't I do this because Hamilton
parodies have been done to death and the
last year there have been more parodies
of the musical Hamilton than there have
been performances of the musical
Hamilton okay that may be true I'm sure
a lot of parties out there you haven't
seen my Hamilton pair okay
I've seen it man I've seen them all I've
seen the Hamilton parody about MC Hammer
called called Alexander hammertime I've
seen a commercial featuring Denny's
Grand Slam Alton and yes and I've seen
the all-female Hamilton parody called
Alexander ma'am oh boy yes yes sure okay
fine those were all fine those were
great you may think you know all the
Hamilton parodies but did you know that
my Hamilton parody features a secretary
of the Treasury who created the first
centralized Bank and could travel up to
100 miles in the hot desert without
water thanks to his ability to store up
to 80 pounds of fat in his op no no
please please please stop well I'm going
to do this Matthew
I'm not sure you know his name but mark
my words the world's going to know his
name what shall a man
[Applause]
Alexander Hamilton
he's a dromedary secretary of the
Treasury just to weigh the schools
[Applause]
well Matthew what did you think
I'm curious serious I'm curious with
envy oh yeah you have improved in the
original this is jr. you're great
his name is Alexander Hamilton Alexander
Hamilton
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you